now to what may be a crucial moment in
the Justice Department's investigation
of Donald Trump's efforts to overturn
the 2020 election former vice president
Mike Pence testified to a grand jury
yesterday despite former president
Donald Trump fighting for months to stop
that very thing from happening Barbara
Costa is on Capitol Hill for us he's
been following all of it Bob good
morning wasn't a short visit either
not at all good morning Tony it is
really a grand jury that has been busy
for months hearing testimony from former
Trump Administration officials but never
before in American history has a former
vice president been compelled to testify
about the president he served alongside
former vice president Mike Pence left
the D.C courthouse on Thursday after
hours of testimony before the D.C grand
jury looking into January 6. and former
president Trump's pressure campaign to
overturn the 2020 election
[Applause]
Trump had leaned on Pence privately and
publicly to stop the certification of
the election in Congress which he
refused to do I hope Mike is going to do
the right thing I hope so Trump
asserting executive privilege tried
repeatedly to stop pens from testifying
about their interactions on that day and
the days leading up to the attack on the
capitol but on Wednesday an appeals
court cleared the path for pens to
appear to testify in your view about the
private conversations you have had with
President Trump people can be confident
that we'll
will obey the law will comply with the
law now with Pence moving closer to
entering the race for the White House
his testimony could affect the legal and
political fate of his potential rival
there may be no better Star witness for
the special counsel former Federal
prosecutor Scott Fredrickson says
Pence's appearance could mean the grand
jury's work is coming to an end this is
indeed probably the most significant
witness and the most difficult witness
to get into the grand jury so one would
think that the special counsel is very
close to making his decision about
whether to charge or not sources tell
CBS news that Penn's prepared
extensively for this testimony going
over notes and details about the January
6th story with his lawyers as well as
the the bounds of his testimony what he
could and could not say based on prior
legal rulings Nate
Bob thank you